c'est vrai que c'est un champignon c'est
un champignon qui s'attrape à l'eau
contact donc on touche sur des draps ça
peut être sur des surfaces et en fait
effectivement quand vous êtes malade en
général quand vous êtes à l'hôpital
c'est que vous n'êtes pas très en forme
vous pouvez l'attraper si vous êtes
infecté en fait vous êtes grande chance
de mourir parce qu'on a aucun traitement
efficace qui est ultra résistant aux
antifongiques classiques donc
effectivement c'est inquiète parce que
c'est découvert effectivement au Japon
en 2006 en fait ça gagne du terrain et
si tous les hôpitaux commencent à être
contaminés par ce type de champignons en
fait à chaque fois que vous allez avoir
des gens qui vont l'attraper alors
qu'ils sont venus pour une autre cause
qui du coup risque de mourir et vous
pouvez rien faire parce que vous avez
aucun traitement c'est pour ça que les
silicium américain c'est-à-dire l'organe
qui surveille ce genre de choses est
très inquiet parce que ça progresse aux
États-Unis étape par état hôpitaux par
hôpitaux et donc à chaque fois que vous
avez ça dans un hôpital c'est un vrai
problème en plus c'est extrêmement
compliqué à gérer ça arrive dans les
hôpitaux et ça arrive dans les hôpitaux
parce que c'est là qu'en fait que vous
quand vous quand vous l'attrapez vous
pouvez pas rattraper si vous avez un
système immunitaire qui fonctionne donc
c'est là où les gens qui ont un système
immunitaire défaillant sont donc c'est
dans les hôpitaux et donc c'est
les médecins le peuvent l'attraper de
coloniser mais ils vont pas être très
malade parce que eux ils ont système
immunitaires qui fonctionnent donc
effectivement il y en a pas beaucoup en
France il y en a eu en Espagne en Europe
et en Angleterre mais ça risque
d'arriver ouais c'est déjà en Europe
effectivement en Espagne et en
Angleterre et donc ouais mais c'est que
ça fait quand même flipper parce que
c'est chaud pour donc à l'hôpital ça
fait flipper des médecins ça fait
flipper à l'hôpital une petite
intervention tu as ton système
immunitaire qui est un peu défaillant et
donc là tu peux attraper le champignon
tu peux tu peux y passer voilà c'est
chaud tu peux tu viens pour un panari tu
peux sortir
et quand on dit pas très malade pardon
ça veut dire c'est quel symptôme si on
est en bonne non mais ça veut dire que
en gros en gros les gens les gens qui
l'attrape c'est les gens par exemple qui
sont traités pour un cancer et quand un
système immunitaire très mauvais les
gens qui ont une maladie immunitaire
avec des traitements qui leur plombe
leur système immunitaire donc c'est tous
les gens qui sont très malades mais je
veux dire quand c'est pas mortel quels
sont les symptômes c'est pas mortel on
est pas malade en fait on l'a mais on
s'en rend même pas compte on est
jusqu'au colonisé
Jean-Michel non je vous dis ce qu'il y a
pas de traitement donc c'est pour ça
qu'il est très dangereux mais si ça se
développe les médecins les chercheurs
vont travailler dessus on va peut-être
trouver un vaccin ou quelque chose comme
ça s'appelle on est battu là mais en
fait on a utilisé tellement
dentifongique que ce genre de
champignons a été a été sélectionné
parce qu'il est très résistant et donc
en fait émerger effectivement des
champignons mais il y a pas que les
champignons il y a plein d'autres il y a
des bactéries qui sont résistantes comme
ça et qui se propagent et contre lequel
on a du mal à lutter
ce n'est qu'une forme peut-être de
maladie nos écomiale nosocomiale a donc
on peut dans les hôpitaux quand on est
faible c'est une maladie on risque
d'avoir c'est une maladie nosocomiale
mais c'est une maladie nosocomiale
nouvelle c'est pour ça que c'est
inquiète qui progresse rapidement et
effectivement sur lesquels les
traitements ne fonctionnent quasiment
pas donc c'est vrai que c'est une menace
c'est pour ça que ça a été identifié et
que le but c'est éviter que ça gagne ou
plutôt par hôpitaux parce qu'après c'est
trop bien quelle est la différence parce
que on parle aussi du staphylocoque doré
ça n'a rien à voir ben c'est le
staphylocoque de doré c'est bactéries là
c'est un champignon le staphylocoque
doré une bactérie un champignon
complètement différents qui sont pas du
tout les mêmes la bactérie c'est un
petit organisme indépendant qui est dans
votre corps de façon habituelle vous en
avez par exemple dans votre système
digestif vous en avez un peu partout et
parfois et puis les champignons c'est
quelque chose quand même de beaucoup
plus rare qui se développe pas forcément
une température et contre lesquelles on
a beaucoup plus de mal à lutter c'est
plus dangereux quoi un champignon c'est
plus chiant les champignons c'est assez
classique de ces bactéries de ces
microorganismes nosocomio qui sont à
l'hôpital et effectivement quand vous
avez un système immunitaire défaillant
c'est très très difficile de lutter
contre ces questions et questions aussi
voilà moi si je suis en bonne santé et
j'ai le j'ai le champignon il y a pas de
est-ce que je peux le prendre est-ce que
je peux le transmettre à une personne
qui est en mauvaise santé oui vous
pouvez le transmettre mais vous allez
pas le porter longtemps en fait quand
même plus vous êtes en mauvaise santé
plus il va pouvoir se développer et plus
vous allez quand même le transmettre aux
autres personnes et comment je vais
mettre ça peut être avec toi c'est du
contact vraiment
covid tout ça il faut il faut il faut
toucher personne à l'hôpital à l'hôpital
même partout
je m'en fous là tu sais rien on s'en
fout il va me serrer la main là
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à de vous
serrer la main sans déconner dégâts
veulent me serrer la main là quand ils
ont rendez-vous avec moi qu'est-ce que
je m'en fous là
et puis c'est tout on continue la raison
Géraldine la lourdeur tu sais c'est bon
maintenant les gens ils veulent
absolument et quand tu veux bien sûr
moi je leur dis direct tu as raison
j'ai l'impression que chaque semaine
chaque mois dont on parlait d'un virus
qui va tous nous tuer là c'est un
champignon est-ce qu'on n'est pas devenu
parano depuis le covid comme ça dont on
parlait pas parce qu'il y a pas le covid
bah on se regarde plus depuis quelques
bits c'est vrai mais ça c'était regarder
avant le covid et ça inquiétait déjà et
là c'est la rapidité auquel ça progresse
mais c'est un problème qui est très
hospitalier on va pas être tous mourir
de champignons là mais à chaque fois que
vous allez à l'hôpital
et vous risquez d'attraper ça c'est il y
a des gens qui ont un faible système
immunitaire mais qui sont pas à
l'hôpital ils peuvent l'attraper aussi
dans la vraie vie vous avez plus de
chance d'aller à l'hôpital quand même
quand vous êtes très malade vous avez
une maladie vous devez avoir des soins
assez lourds fréquemment qu'est-ce qu'il
y a
moi j'ai une question à vous poser là
pour l'instant c'est les personnes quand
un faible système immunitaire c'était
pareil avec le covid au début c'est que
les personnes âgées 80 ans est-ce qu'on
a est-ce que ça peut arriver sur des
personnes est-ce qu'il peut muter et
arriver sur des personnes qui sont en
bonne santé il va se stopper
une épidémie éclair qui touche tout le
monde et qui va extrêmement vite parce
que ça passe dans l'air j'ai quelque
chose au contact qui est essentiellement
chez des gens et Mélodie frénés c'est
vraiment un problème de l'hôpital des
médecins et c'est vrai que si parfois
vous avez des hôpitaux qui sont
contaminés par ce type de champignons
vous êtes obligé de prendre des mesures
drastiques quasiment fermé des des
parties
il a raison et puis et là là c'est l'OMS
a quand même classé ce champignon comme
priorité critique pour la santé publique
et on peut l'attraper qu'à l'hôpital
essentiellement
dans une épicerie impossible
en fait vous allez vous allez à travers
vous êtes très vite vous en débarrasser
parce que vous êtes en capacité de vous
ouais je crois que c'est 1400 aux
États-Unis en France quasiment pas mais
il y a des épidémies ouais qui plusieurs
milliers ça peut arriver ça va arriver
ça ça va chier les bulletins oui une des
grandes questions sur le covid c'était
l'origine on sait toujours pas est-ce
que ce champignon on sait j'ai lu par
exemple c'était peut-être une
surconsommation d'antibiotiques ou le
réchauffement climatique
on sait pas on sait qu'il est apparu
mais effectivement il y a forcément des
facteurs qui l'ont fait émerger et
effectivement notamment une des pistes
c'est que il serait capable de résister
à des températures plus élevées que les
autres champignons et que ça pourrait
être expliquer effectivement par bon ça
c'est assez hypothétique le résister à
Bernard Montiel qui sort d'un UV euh
vous dites que c'est essentiellement à
l'hôpital mais alors comment est-ce que
vous expliquez que par exemple ça ça
démarre au Japon puis on le retrouve aux
États-Unis puis ensuite en Europe parce
que vous dites qu'il y a pas de porteur
sain qui peuvent ensuite le le porter
ailleurs comme pour le covid
moi ce que ça peut apparaître dans
différents
la planète en quelques semaines là en un
an on a doublé aux États-Unis donc c'est
quand même beaucoup beaucoup plus lent
mais c'est le même principe sauf que ça
va beaucoup moins vite et les gens
voyagent et c'est comme ça que ça passe
d'un continental Géraldine ceux qui sont
à l'hôpital et qui sont immunodéprimé
donc le shop il risque de mourir et ceux
qui ne meurent pas alors qu'ils sont
imminent déprimés qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
pris comme traitement pour pas mourir
bah on leur donne des antifongiques mais
dans 60 à 70% des cas ça ne marche pas
donc parfois ça fonctionne et parfois ça
fonctionne pas mais là les données sont
quand même pas extraordinaire
le champignon qui se répand partout dans
votre corps en général ça monsieur
fatale non mais c'est bon
[Rires]
attention aucun aucun racisme mais le
covid vient de Chine ça ça vient du
Japon il se passe un petit truc en Asie
quand même bah on a dit déjà vous avez
beaucoup de monde qui a une probabilité
que ça part de like et quand même
relativement importante et tout ne pars
pas d'Asie il y a des choses qui sont
partis d'Afrique comme kipox par exemple
je préférais celle de Géraldine
en fait attention
sur les muqueuses ou la peau est-ce
qu'il y a par exemple une irritation de
la peau qui peut faire détecter ça à
l'hôpital ou comment s'en apercevoir
avant que ce soit trop grave
c'est des gens qui ont de la fièvre ils
ont un phénomène infectieux et ça
commence à avoir des symptômes qui
touchent les différents organes qui sont
atteints donc c'est vraiment un syndrome
infectieux assez classique pas du tout
spécifique alors oui Mathieu
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet
[Musique]
non mais je pense que je suis pas je
suis peut-être pas inquiète tout de
suite mais c'est vrai que c'est le truc
dérive ça peut être très embêtant
effectivement pour les centres
anticancéreux et ça peut poser des vrais
problèmes c'est maintenant que votre
inquiet Martin pardon mais si j'étais
une fois que ça a dérivé c'est trop tard
[Rires]
quand même les Américains disent
alarmants alarmant ça veut dire que pour
eux c'est alerte rouge quand même non
mais c'est une menace parce qu'on sait
pas comment on va l'arrêter en fait
autant voilà et c'est à partir du moment
où ça commence à progresser vous savez
pas comment vous l'arrêtez donc c'est
vrai oui et à partir du moment où là
docteur on peut mourir en combien de
temps c'est un peu non mais ça peut
aller vite à partir du moment où c'est
une infection fongique
je détecte ils disent on peut on peut
rien faire
vous allez en réanimation et puis
ensuite on essaie des traitements ça
marche pas et voilà alors
comment on sait qu'on l'a eu on l'a
chopé parce que non c'est rien c'est
quoi les symptômes c'est pas là en fait
c'est des patients extrêmement
compliqués
ils découvrent que c'est ça ils essaient
des traitements ça ne fonctionne pas
plus de cas que ce qu'on dit peut-être
non mais ce que veut dire Cyril c'est
est-ce qu'on peut avoir
non mais
c'est pas du tout comme la symptomatique
du covid tout ça là c'est vraiment dans
des cas très précis donc en général on
cherche on est à 5h les gens vont quand
même vraiment pas bien donc on n'est pas
sur des choses sous-estimées en effet il
y a des moyens de se faire dépister
parce que dès le début du covid il y
avait les tests non non mais c'est pas
du tout le même sujet c'est vraiment sur
des sujets très spécifiques en réa et
non le problème c'est pas un sous
diagnostics je la réserve Hervé Vilard
qui serait
[Rires]
non mais ça fait ça fait flipper Martin
donc c'est des gens en France
ça commence à rêver ça arrivera
probablement si on n'arrive pas enrayer
cette progression et je vois pas comment
ils vont l'oreiller parce que là ils
arrêtent ça fait plusieurs années qu'ils
essayent il n'y arrive pas donc voilà
mais c'est des choses qu'on a déjà vu
est-ce qu'en France c'est important de
nous dire où c'est dans quel
établissement dans quel hôpital et tout
ça est-ce qu'il y a une transparence par
rapport à ça non mais oui
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait que ce soit
totalement faux
c'est hyper hyper rare quoi c'est Sika
en France probablement dans quelques
établissements
on meurt dans les 15 jours ça va
vraiment arriver chez nous mais bon on
peut rien faire
[Rires]
pourquoi on parle plus du tout du covid
bah parce que c'est au niveau de la
grippe maintenant c'est ça
considéré que c'est pas
ça c'est une question c'est c'est mort
c'est parce que il y a d'autres
priorités ou c'est vraiment on s'est
habitué à vivre avec et que c'est
militaire sont relativement entraînés
maintenant avec le micro et que on y
survit très bien on dit qu'il y a une
petite vaguette qui revient
tous les quatre mois on aura des vagues
covid comme on a des vagues de
rhinopharyngite ou un peu moins des
vagues de grippe de bronchite ouais mais
il change plus il y a plus des variants
différents maintenant il y a plus en
fait c'est de plus en plus c'est des
sous-sous-sous-famille donc plus on
avance plus ressemble les uns les autres
mais il varie quand même mais dans un
spectre beaucoup plus étroit ça reste de
l'eau micron assez léger voilà et donc
quoi le covid c'est fini ouais le covid
c'est sans doute fini ouais vraiment la
crise telle qu'on l'a connu c'est sans
doute fini on aura des gens assez
fragiles qu'il attraperont comme ils
attrape la grippe mais ça va pas devenir
un problème gravissime comme ça a été
est-ce qu'on en a trop fait après
avec un peu de recul est-ce qu'on en a
trop fait sur le sur le covid
un peu de recul mais évidemment oui on
en a trop fait tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire ça
c'était beaucoup trop le premier coup
si aujourd'hui on avait à le refaire
évidemment qu'on refait pas ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est vrai mais
tout le monde est d'accord en fait un
sujet de base c'est vaccination ni les
masques ni rien non mais probablement
que première vague si on savait
exactement ce que c'était et que les
gens n'avaient pas été menuisé parce
qu'on ne savait sur une population
vierge c'était des variantes quand même
relativement costaud mais on aurait fait
le modèle à la suédoise c'est-à-dire bar
resto et quelques mesures les grands
événements ce serait passé ça aurait pas
été tellement pire que ce que ça a été
mais on savait pas voilà mais c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on referait jamais ça et je
pense qu'on le refera pas exactement ce
que division disait exactement
en médecine c'est pas Martin qui va me
mais non mais le principe
bien sûr oui on est on les a tous on les
a tous jetés oui mais elle savait pas
mais il valait mieux c'est pas
grand-chose
le docteur le personnel soignant n'y est
absolument pour rien mais on a de plus
en plus l'impression qu'on chope
beaucoup de maladies à l'hôpital quand
même plus quand même ça fait presque ou
presque les jetons à l'hôpital je te
jure il a raison à chaque fois moi je
vois des mecs qui sont à l'hôpital ils
ont rien ils reviennent il faut essayer
d'être d'hospitaliser le moins possible
moi je suis d'accord avec ça il faudra
essayer que les gens soient le plus en
plus pris en charge en dehors de
l'hôpital après parfois vous avez pas le
choix et vous pouvez ressortir de
l'hôpital sans infections
bah merci pour la phrase mais c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est vrai on a
un système français qui est très centré
sur l'hôpital et on devrait avoir un
système où on essaie de soigner les gens
en dehors de l'hôpital le plus possible
et ça c'est une réalité et après il y a
un côté historique qui fait que on a été
très centré sur l'hôpital mais ça
changera probablement dans les années à
venir donc il y a pas de ouais c'est
c'est mais où en dehors de l'hôpital il
y a pas le médecin traitant
chez vous des infirmières deux minutes
deux minutes s'il vous plaît priorité il
est dessus d'accord très bien merci
c'était Willy denze il voulait savoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]